[Musique]
vincent nico est avec nous applaudissent
[Applaudissements]
beau il est bon d'aller regarder cette
classe b st gall et l'arrière aux et or
à chauny cauet mais durent toute la vie
un excellent sauvage il va vous chantez
des génériques télé à vous de trouver de
quoi il s'agit dès que vous avez la
bonne réponse vous lever la main la la
la la la
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ouais
[Applaudissements]
à
sans les taxes sur les dark fall et d'un
solide au
tu peux tu peux toucher ma bouche et m'a
dit qu'on rêve pas d'avoir des cheveux
comme ça et ça c'est magnifique soirée
nous on avait souvent dire des tapis de
sol oui oui oui oui
[Musique]
alors
là
oh
non
aulas
lolo
à quelle foi quand même énorme oui et
oui on l'a vu ce week end les gars mais
l'on n'est pas loin de france amène à
quoi ça peut être un jeu et ont gagné
des mini blog sur allagnon aimé ta voix
[Musique]
qui dure toute la vie
pas
vous chantez your world award for me for
me formidable avec les lieux sûrs oui
oui le v8 bleus
[Musique]
c'est à peu près tout you are the one
roly poly blida
ban à la barre
demi moore
maman
la la la la
ah là là lol
là
le motus oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pas mal ça
chagrin qui excellent vincent michaud
que j'adore j'adore ce garçon
[Musique]